the long-awaited follow-up to The Legend
of Zelda breath of the wild is finally
almost here The Legend of Zelda tears of
the kingdom is coming May 12 2023 even
as close as we are though there's a lot
that's still a mystery Nintendo is
notoriously secretive about its games
before launch and it seems especially
inclined to keep this anticipated Zelda
game under wraps but here's everything
we do know about tears of the Kingdom
[Music]
of all its most closely guarded secrets
of the plot of The Legend of Zelda tears
of the kingdom is perhaps the one held
tightest to Nintendo's proverbial chest
the game will serve as a direct sequel
to its predecessor breath of the wild
which makes it the title set farthest in
the series timeline for a full rundown
of how all the games in the franchise
link to one another check out our
complete Zelda Timeline video but for
now here's a quick recap of the events
of breath of the wild to get you caught
up on the immediate story 100 years
before the start of breath of the wild a
prophecy tells of the return of Calamity
Ganon an evil that could take over the
kingdom of Hyrule in search of something
powerful enough to face this threat the
hillians unearth the Guardians and four
Divine beasts ancient but also Advanced
technological Creations that were until
then lost to time champions from 4 the
Kingdom's tribes were given the
responsibility of piloting the Divine
beasts while the night's link was tasked
with protecting Princess Zelda the only
person capable of learning the magic
needed to seal away Calamity Ganon in an
event known as the great Calamity Ganon
is able to take control of the Guardians
render the Divine beasts and nerd and
Gravely wound link Zelda has her Knight
taken to the shrine of Resurrection to
heal and uses her limited magical
abilities to contain Ganon and herself
in Hyrule Castle link awakens 100 years
later and learns from the spirit of
hyrule's King Rome the Ganon has been
gaining strength in the time since being
sealed away and will soon be strong
enough to break free from his prison
link travels across the kingdom and
frees the four Divine beasts from the
blights that rendered the minert with
the mechanical creatures in tow piloted
by the spirits of their Champions link
faces Ganon and with the help of Zelda
is able to seal the ancient evil away
before for declaring that Hyrule will be
rebuilt tears of the Kingdom looks to
pick up before that can happen however
with the return of Ganon now in his
humanoid form Ganondorf who seemingly
manages to separate Link and Zelda
forcing the princess's Knights to forge
a new quest to finding her and once
again facing down the ancient cyclical
evil
much like breath of the wild tears of
the Kingdom will take place in an open
world which is seemingly a heavily
modified version of the Hyrule we
experience in the first game like that
title players will be free to explore it
at their Leisure utilizing several
abilities to get around with the first
ability is recore this can be cast on an
object forcing it to rewind in time the
key usage of this ability allows the
player to reverse time on parts of the
Game's new sky islands that have fallen
to the ground below allowing link to
hitch a ride on them to get to the
aerial areas we have also seen examples
of recall being used in combat such as
rewinding time on a boulder that has
been rolled in an attempt to squish link
only for it to roll backwards and squash
the enemies that pushed it instead the
next abilities are fuse and Ultra hand
the former allows link to take items
from his inventory to combine them such
as attaching a rock to the end of a
stick to create a makeshift Hammer a
mushroom to a shield to create a smoke
screen when it's hit or an eyeball to an
arrow to allow it home in on a Target
the latter ability takes fuse to the
next level by allowing link to grab
almost any inanimate object in the
Overworld and combining them to create
large scale Contraptions particularly
for traversal this can range from simple
rafts composed of several logs and fans
for propulsion to primitive robots that
link can wield like a Mech in combat the
final new ability is Ascend in breath of
the wild to get on top of any surface
link would more often than not need to
scale the side of it expending stamina
to do so and in turn risking a nasty
Fall Tears of the Kingdom expedites this
process in certain scenarios with Ascend
an ability that allows link to jump
through any ceiling to pop out the other
side on top this can be done in both a
thin covering or something as
substantial as the side of a mountain
that link is inside a cave at the base
of swimming through the rock till he
reaches the plateau above beyond the new
abilities tears of the Kingdom looks to
expand on the core gameplay of breath of
the wild weapon degradation is still a
thing although it seems as if fusing
weapons with other objects restores
their Vitality link will have his trusty
glider which he's going to need even
more in tears of the Kingdom as he is
able to free fall from the sky islands
to the land below at any time and shield
surfing seems to be getting a
substantial upgrade with trailers
showing off link grinding along rails
development on tears of the Kingdom
began in 2017 the same year as the
release of breath of the wild the game
stemmed from ideas that the team
initially intended for use in breath of
the Wild's DLC but series producer IG
ionuma claims that there were too many
ideas they had to leave on The Cutting
Room floor that they instead decided to
use as the foundation of a new title
Wrath of the Wild's game director
hidamura fujibayashi is also returning
to helm tears of the Kingdom the game
was first shown off at E3 2019 and for
years went under the name of the sequel
to breath of the wild in 2020 it was
given a release window of 2022 however
in March 2022 Nintendo released a video
to announce the game would be delayed to
2023 and in September of that year the
title received its official name tears
of the Kingdom along with the release
date of May 12 2023 in March 2023 during
an extensive Hands-On demonstration of
The Game's new abilities I confirmed
that development of the game had been
completed
with development of the game complete
tears of the Kingdom will hit its
release date of May 12 2023 it is the
first switch game from Nintendo to
launch at 70 which the company has
stated is not a blanket pricing for all
its future titles while the game is ten
dollars more expensive than previously
priced Nintendo titles it will be
available as a part of the Nintendo
switch online Voucher Program which
allows switch online subscribers to buy
a 100 voucher that they can use to
redeem two games full details at
gamespot.com for which other games can
also be redeemed via this process there
is a 130 collector's edition of the game
that includes a physical copy of it a
steelbook case poster pin set and art
book Nintendo also released several
tiers of the Kingdom peripherals
including a 25 carrying case and 75
dollar Pro Controller a tears of the
Kingdom themed switch OLED model is out
now as well the collector's edition as
well as the switch OLED and accessories
are all subject to availability and
that's everything we know about tears of
the Kingdom before its release while we
don't know much about the Game's plot or
if it will score a 10 out of 10 at
Gamespot like its predecessor we
couldn't be more excited to return to
Hyrule let us know your hype levels for
tears of the kingdom in the comments
below
[Music]
foreign